we're talking about the beginnings of
the public ministry of Jesus
the predecessor John the Baptist his
baptism and his for a sermon in Nazareth
David what what do you make of Luke's
report on John the Baptist and his
preaching well first of all Luke is the
only one of the Gospel writers who tells
us that John the Baptist is Jesus cousin
and I think that's indicative of the
close relationship between the two that
these are people whose ministries in
continuity not a discontinuity like all
the Gospel writers Luke has to deal with
John the Baptist I think there's a
historical reality beyond this I have no
doubt that there was a very close
relationship in the ministry of Jesus to
John the Baptist and that each of the
Gospel writers reflects this but it
strikes me that that that John does two
things and just as we were talking about
last time there's both continuity and
discontinuity that that he in some ways
proclaims the same gospel of repentance
that he's going to that we're going to
hear from Jesus only Jesus brings it
even more that the ages of justice and
mercy that will be there in Jesus
ministry are already foreshadowed in
John but also he he brings Jesus down to
the place of baptism where Jesus can be
declared as God's own son so that Jesus
is in continuity with John and yet
immeasurably greater than John and that
Luke tells us both those things mm-hmm
there are two things in that account of
John the Baptist that strike me one is
they prophesy that it's supposedly being
fulfilled in Luke three six all flesh
shall see the salvation of God that
strikes me as a particularly important
Lucan theme right and then that the
content of John's preaching and teaching
what do you make of that the all flesh
it seems to me is yes because one of the
things Luke ash wants to tell us that
that this gospel will be spread to the
ends of the earth
so what strikes me about the content of
the preaching is that it is in some ways
relatively modest that that tax
collectors are not told to stop being
tax collectors they've told us stop
extorting and that soldiers are not told
to become passive us but they're told to
do what they do justly and so that in
some ways one of the commentators say
it's kind of a bourgeois ethic which
means that we do what we're going to do
but we do it with integrity
with justice and that's a striking piece
which I relates to some of the things
we've been talking about about our
guests on loose audience that these are
these are maybe relatively comfortable
people who are told to use their
relative power in ways that are more
just what I love about it is toward the
very end and I'm just gonna have to get
the verse right Jesus says that John the
Baptist has been preaching good news to
the people and I'm puzzled that he
thinks that all these kind of
descriptions about what you're supposed
to do to shape up your life is somehow
good news you got any clue what he means
by that I haven't found my verse there
you got it yeah I'm not sure of the
precise verse but I think you're right
that what John is portrayed as preaching
here is Contin continuous with what Luke
wants to inculcate is an important part
of the Gospel message and the and the
Gospel message is that you repent you
change you become different but their
difference has some kind of continuity
with what's going before right I want to
shift to the the story of the Baptist
armed forces and just make one kind of
general comment that in a lot of Luke we
have important parallels in both Matthew
and in mark and sometimes we get a sense
of what Luke is up to by comparing his
account of Matthew and my what about the
baptism of Jesus do you see anything
specific there that's telling for what
Luke is up to him so let me preface it
so in Luke what we have is a gospel
that's parallel in many ways to Matthew
and 2 to mark as three synoptic Gospels
they'll tell a lot of the same tales but
Luke tells them in a very specific way
sometimes is there it's something that
we can say about Luke's intention by
looking let's say at the baptism of
Jesus and how he portrays it well I
think in part he sees it as a public
event and then what happens is the
coming of the Spirit and the
proclamation which is there for all the
people not only for Jesus and not only
for believers and this will be echoed
again in the Transfiguration story where
once again God speaks well another point
in Luke that we sometimes underestimate
is what an important character God is
that that while it's true absolutely
true that
that both Zechariah and and Mary
proclaim what's going to happen to
humankind they're proclaiming what God
is going to do and in this case God's
own self speaks and says all right now
I'm going to interpret this story for
you you Jesus are my son the beloved and
I take pleasure in you mm-hmm
right so it's public and it ties in with
this theme of all flesh shall see the
salvation of God from that prophetic
text earlier on and then the genealogy
of Jesus that follows they the baptism
story that brings things back to Adam
all the way to Adam so you've got a
universal story that begins at the very
beginning does echo Paul at that point
where the story starts with Adam and
goes to Christ I think in both Romans
and first corinthians also along with
that there's the fact that the spirit
descends on jesus mm-hm and one of the
striking things about luke's gospel is
the power of the spirit time after time
after time so here the spirit descends
we'll see in the sermon that comes a
little later in the same passage about
those spirit falls on jesus at that
point the spirit falls on the apostles
at the at the story of pentecost i was
thinking when we were when we were
getting ready for this hymn that I do in
my youth that was certainly a big among
Baptist Spirit of God descend upon my
heart wean it from earth and it seems to
me that Luke's Gospel is almost the
opposite that Spirit of God descend upon
our arts and send us out to all the
earth but the Spirit is the empowering
not the separating when it's the one
that makes mission and community
possible not the one that I chase off in
my in my privacy and and a kind of
counter to our sense that spirituality
is what you do all by yourself that holy
spirituality is what you do in community
for the world that sounds like a very
Catholic theme of the Bible I pleasure
could we do that do they have the text
that you referred to in Luke 4 where
Jesus comes to nathir Nazareth gives his
first sermon and talks about the spirit
what do you make of that that passage
and well I mean first of all he both
quotes a prophet and becomes a prophet I
think at that point that he's drawing on
the text from Isaiah the Spirit of the
Lord is upon me which the prophet Isaiah
second Isaiah certainly spoke of as
self-referential and now Jesus says
alright
I'm in that I am in that line I'm in the
line of the prophets but also I think
once again as with John the Baptist I'm
even more than that I'm the one in whom
that is not only somewhat adumbrated I'm
the one whom that is embodied the
fullness of that promise is now embody a
lot of people think that this is a
promise for what's supposed to happen in
the Jubilee year what God let's free
captives and pronounces good news to the
poor and Jesus in some ways is saying
alright all those expectations about
what God does in history are now
fulfilled in my own person I'm the one
who does that mmm-hmm are they fulfilled
in some sort of political program do you
think I don't know I wish I knew I think
a great word that we toss around a new
gentleman clause is is proleptic which
is that it begins now and it's yet to be
fulfilled and we don't I think in in
Luke's Gospel get a full political
program but I think we get enough
glimpses of the kingdom of God that
people who have political concerns can
say alright here's a vision of what our
politics ought to work toward I don't
want to say that politics are totally
divorced from this vision on the other
hand I don't think it's the Lucan party
program some kind of tricky balance
between those two mmm what do you think
well I think we have a hint at Luke's
theology of the church yeah okay and I
think Luke sees the the vision of the
the year of the Lord's favor being
realized somehow as Christian the tree
that's why he goes on into accent yeah
well the Spirit comes again the other
thing that strikes me about it is that
as with the prophets Jesus gets rejected
here so once again we see him as being
being one very much like the prophets
and he will talk about the Prophet not
being welcome in his own community and
it's not I thought at first I've been
many times over this and I assumed okay
it's his presumption they're annoyed
because he says all right this is
fulfilled in me and I think oh my
goodness how presumptuous to think that
he's the one in whom all this has come
to pass but it's not that is that he
won't stick around and do miracles for
them they're annoyed because he's not
cashing in on his own value at this
point for them and if I come to Yale
Divinity School announced on the Messiah
then I ought to raise a bunch of money
before I leave right I hope you do
exactly
and we all live in hope and so there's
this sense that somehow he's not for
this group he's not ready for to fulfill
the expectations they have what's that
about why does he why didn't he just
stop to do two miracles in Nazareth
before he heads out mm-hmm
an interesting question I'm not sure I
can give you an answer the matter
there's another dimension to it as Jesus
goes on to talk about himself and his
relationships with the prophetic
tradition he cites those prophets that
had something to do with Gentiles so he
puts himself in that prophetic tradition
and he also sets up this dichotomy
that's so very important to Luke between
Jew and Gentile yeah and we've heard the
prophetic text already that all flesh is
going to see the salvation of God it's
going to be a universal outrage and
that's going to be the story of Acts and
Jesus is here already putting a little
bit yeah pushing toward it and getting
some pushback so we have an anticipation
of that great theme that's going to run
through accent the pushback against that
Universal message that Paul encountered
well I think I think a theme we're going
to see already in the gospel and people
will see as they look at access does
that mean that Israel is now excluded do
we now move beyond Nazareth and head for
Athens basically or is it the case that
that we we come together the kind of
Paul I envision that Israel and the
Gentiles well praise God together in the
kingdom right sometimes Luke I think is
being accused is accused of being a
Super Session s and someone who rejects
the the Israelite heritage I think
that's quite a misreading of Luke and
the the insistence throughout these
first several chapters of continuity and
so he can't tell the story without his
real story any can tell the story
without Abraham mm-hmm Thanks